well if you're planning to hike run or
walk this weekend and want to make a
difference in the lives of local kids
battling rare diseases you have a
wonderful opportunity
world rare disease day is this sunday
and the little miss hannah foundation
locally puts on an event each year to
heighten the awareness of childhood rare
diseases and raise money to provide
families necessary devices and medical
equipment for free for their children
parents carrie and robert austria
started the foundation in honor of their
three-year-old daughter hannah
who lost her battle with a rare disease
at the age of three as we mentioned
we've got some video from their prior 5k
walk and runs which we've covered over
the years here at 8 news now
we've been honored to be emcees for
several years at the event as well
this year they've gone virtual for the
safety of everyone involved
we encourage people to go out run your
race it doesn't have to be a 5k
it doesn't have to be a one mile could
be a marathon if you want take a picture
upload it to social media and kind of
join in the fun that way we're just
appreciative of the community it's been
very supportive
uh you know we're all we still are
accepting registrations for those who
you know we have a t-shirt back there we
have a medal that comes with it
vegas cares about rare.org you can
register and sign up and again
you know all of the proceeds goes
towards our programs and this past year
volunteers were able to deliver 45
pieces of equipment directly to local
families
through the medical and therapy
equipment program due to last year's
annual fundraiser
again the virtual race is this sunday
you can still register those who do
get that t-shirt and a medal sent to
them in the mail go to vegas
cares about rare